with 700 hours invested in the first
OverWatch what I longed for from
OverWatch 2 was a lot of meaningful
changes that pushed the series forward
while also remaining faithful to the
identity at first forged the identity
which made me someone not typically
interested in games driven solely by
their multiplayer elements such a big
fan of the first OverWatch and in some
ways OverWatch 2 delivers this offering
up new characters that feel at home
among the rest of the season roster
making the jump to 5v5 which is
brilliant and adding an enthralling push
mode
even better the game does all this while
retaining the same compelling back and
forth flow of battle and core gameplay
that fans love however these are tweaks
and additions in a game that otherwise
feels very familiar and that sameness
can sometimes make this new OverWatch
feel more like an update than something
brand new in the way that the two
suggests beyond that however OverWatch 2
often feels detached from the principles
and charm of the original one of the
greatest changes to OverWatch 2 comes in
the shape of its new 5v5 combat while
OverWatch featured six Heroes on each
team generally two damage to support and
two tanks OverWatch 2 eliminates one of
these tanks shrinking each team by one
and subsequently altering the dynamic of
battles little side scraps are nowhere
near as common as with only one tank
soaking up damage it becomes vital that
the whole team is there to support them
as well as provide enough of an attack
to break through the other team's
defenses it makes for faster and more
concentrated matches where cooperation
and coordination are crucial in your
every action or inaction feels a lot
more impactful it also means team
composition and understanding how
certain Heroes complement one another
matters far more than ever before this
is as intense as it sounds but the chaos
and Split Second strategizing also make
it incredibly fun with every secured
Victory a meaningful Triumph adding to
OverWatch 2's focus on creating engaging
intense matches is its newest mode push
in push each team is tasked with
reaching the middle of the map where a
robot in two barriers one on either side
await when a team has secured the robot
it begins to push the opposing team's
barrier whichever team covers the most
ground at the end of the match is then
crowned the winner in every game I
played the push and pull of battle was
incredibly tense feeling like a constant
series of tug of war where the tide
could change at any moment playing a
game of OverWatch has never felt quite
as good as it does in OverWatch 2. with
all its intensity it makes sense that
blizzard is going to extreme lengths to
prevents cheating and eliminate toxicity
within the OverWatch Community this
includes things such as requiring
players to register a phone number with
their Battlenet account as well as
eliminating one of overwatch's prized
features Metals these are no longer
doled out at the end of each game and
instead you only see the coveted play of
the game reel followed up by your
individual experience bar filling up
however you can see how your stats stack
up against your teammates and enemies at
any time with the touch of a button
making the elimination of metals seem
pointless for me the satisfaction of
earning medals during a match was a huge
incentive as they made me want to grow
as a player and help me identify when
certain teammates or opponents were
showing off some serious skills which
also contributed to how I gave out
commendations it's a subtle Omission but
one that I certainly felt however it's
hardly the most significant change to
overwatch's reward systems with
OverWatch 2's pivot to free to play also
comes with the introduction of a very
divisive feature in gaming the battle
pass
instead of randomized loot boxes
OverWatch 2 will offer players cosmetic
upgrades through its battle passes which
lasts an entire Nine week-long Season
these battle passes come in free and
premium versions but the premium pass
costing 1 000 OverWatch coins or 10 US
Dollars while I stand by the belief that
randomized loot boxes can be predatory
preying upon people's willingness to
essentially gamble for whatever prizes
they want it's harder for me to decide
just how consumer friendly these
particular battle passes feel blizzard
tries to curtail the notion that buying
the premium battle pass is essential by
touting that all new Heroes which are
scheduled to release every other season
will always be available for free
however everyone who does pay for the
premium battle pass will get these
Heroes instantly while those who don't
will have to level up their battle pass
to tier 55 to unlock them in my time
playing the game the battle passes
didn't level up all that quickly despite
me performing decently in most matches
and even knocking out some of the Game's
new challenges this means players are in
for a long wait if they don't buy the
premium pass and will need to invest a
lot of time into unlocking levels which
feels unfair even with blizzard opting
to keep new characters out of
competitive PVP play for the first few
weeks sure much like in fortnite it's
possible to earn currency through the
battle pass that reduces the cost of a
current premium upgrade which could be
the smartest way to go about it if
you're planning on doing a whole lot of
playing but parts of this feel so at
odds with the spirit of the original
OverWatch which prided itself on not
placing Heroes behind paywalls and
keeping Playing Fields level similarly
for those jumping into OverWatch 2
without having owned the original
OverWatch it has now been revealed that
you'll have to play through a hundred
matches before you're able to use the
entire roster of characters a choice I
find completely bizarre even if I do
understand the intentions behind it the
team calls this decision part of the
game's first time user experience which
is meant to slowly onboard and acclimate
new players to the game however the idea
that players need to log in 10 to 20
hours and prove themselves in order to
unlock other Heroes feels unnecessary in
a bit insult assaulting this is once
again a thing that doesn't feel in the
spirit of OverWatch which encouraged
players to explore and experiment freely
to find what they feel works best for
them that ethos feels disingenuous now
considering a chunk of the roster is
locked away this is hardly the only
issue at launch however while my time
spent playing OverWatch 2 prior to
release was difficult due to the small
number of people playing the game upon
launch slight frustration gave way to
annoyance at times it would take me
hours to log into the game only to be
kicked out after a match this wasn't to
mention the number of difficulties that
was around me reported including
accidentally purchasing skins data
transfer issues and difficulties around
OverWatch 2's previous SMS requirements
while many live service games have bumpy
Beginnings this foray felt especially
jarring it is worth noting however that
blizzard has been actively working on
addressing these issues server queue
times are down significantly the SMS
requirement has been dropped for the
majority of players and on at least
three separate occasions the servers
have been briefly shut down for
maintenance with noticeable improvements
after each update the lack of PVE at
launch is a notable emission considering
this aspect of the game was meant to be
the groundbreaking Monumental feature
that set it apart from its predecessor
it's not merely disappointing to have to
wait until next year to see it it makes
the sequel feel more like an update
simply packaged as a whole new chapter
additionally launching the game with PVE
would have added some much needed heart
and identity to the game that despite
how good it is to play feels like an
exercise in making OverWatch fall in
line with the modern business models for
multiplayer Shooters sure that might
come off as a cynical assessment but it
feels just as cynical as it sounds from
doing away with Winston's inspiring open
speech which very much speaks to the
heart and soul of what OverWatch
represents to the Sleek almost overly
polished new style of the game's menu to
going free to play and implementing a
battle pass OverWatch 2 takes the
franchise from a genre defining shooter
to a trend chasing one as such it has
begun to feel less like a unique sci-fi
superhero comic book in video game form
and more like well a lot of other games
that's not necessarily a bad thing as
many of those other games are superb in
their own right and OverWatch 2's
gameplay certainly lets it hang the
cream of the crop but it comes at the
cost of overwatch's unique aesthetic and
fascinating World which felt diminished
fortunately OverWatch 2 has a major
silver lining in its characters the
subtle changes that older characters
have undergone both cosmetically and in
terms of their abilities feel beneficial
and succeed in giving them that gentle
refresh they needed without disturbing
the magic of their original designs
although it might take some getting used
to not having some key abilities the
push towards making tanks better at
dealing damage makes them a blast and
adds to the more aggressive nature of
OverWatch 2. similarly the characters
like Sombra and Cassidy now hit harder
while Heroes with stuns and freeze
attacks no longer bring games to a
grinding Halt and instead have abilities
that keep the game going and damage
Embers going up even with all these
changes the roster seems to be fairly
balanced an impressive feat when you
have 30 plus characters to consider and
as a newly converted live service title
we can thankfully anticipate this to
stay true while there are sure to be
some Growing Pains as players grow
accustomed to changes occurring more
frequently and their favorite characters
at times being unavailable to play it
could make for a healthier game with
greater longevity I cannot sing enough
Praises for each of the three new Heroes
all of which are excellently designed
and extremely versatile sojourn is a
tactical one-woman Army while junker
Queen's enemy weakening abilities give
that tanky Powerhouse a supportive Edge
kiriko in particular feels like no other
support hero before her is not only can
she pass through walls in order to heal
teammates but she can also deal some
serious damage with her Kanai making her
a fantastic pick for folks who usually
play the DPS role but need to take on a
support role
[Music]
where it counts OverWatch 2 feels like a
fantastic update to a multiplayer game
with mechanics that enable thrilling
skirmishes between teams of Heroes
however as a separate entity and sequel
it stumbles changes to the core
GamePlayer steps in the right direction
but it is surrounded by new points of
friction where there previously were
none thankfully as the live service game
things will be added or altered once
blizzard has more player feedback so at
very least the studio has a strong
Foundation to build upon there is plenty
of good to be found in OverWatch too and
In the Heat of battle the intoxicating
multiplayer dynamics that fans love are
there to enjoy all over again but if the
first OverWatch taught me anything it's
to dream a bit bigger about what games
can be and there still is a lot more
dreaming to be done here
foreign
foreign